Jayda Roden hey David what is being done
today that seems normal but will be
considered primitive or savagery in a
few hundred years I think a lot of it
has to do with medicine right I believe
that in a few hundred years surgery is
going to be so much less invasive that
some of the ways we do surgery today
will be seen almost as savagery but
certainly retrograde in many ways I
think that chemotherapy may be on that
list the idea of something that so
significantly levels decimates systems
of the body in order to attack something
that in some cases at least is localized
depending on the condition that that is
that is being treated I think
chemotherapy is going to be seen as very
very retrograde and more than likely the
technologies that are going to solve
these types of things are combinations
of nanomedicine nanobiology nano
technology combined with customized
medication and we've already talked to a
cancer expert who's researching this who
believes that the next forefront is the
specialization the customization of
treatment plans based on one's
individual biology that's probably the
direction that is going to to really
sort of upend that I do think as someone
who is not vegetarian I do think that
raising animals and killing them for me
the way we do now in a couple hundred
years is probably going to seem pretty
weird because aside from whatever moral
issues one might have with meat-eating I
believe that it is not sustainable nor
justifiable the environmental impact
that the current meat industry status
quo has and I think in a couple hundred
years is gonna be very different and I
think we'll think of of 2018 as like wow
what were they doing back and I think if
lab-grown meats tastes the same and they
are sustainably sourced yeah they have
the same nutritional profile there's
just gonna be no reason to eat yeah
although it might become like a luxury
item like this is real me as opposed to
this was deathless meat or whatever you
want to call it and it would become kind
of like a chic thing of some sort but
that's
okay because that would be drastically
reducing the footprint of or maybe if
your place in the middle of a forest
somewhere if we still have forests
hopefully we do in a few hundred years
we might people will have to survive and
they're gonna kill some animals to do
that right yes
no no question about that but I do think
that there are gonna be changes to meet
do you have any that you I mean we're
talking about a few hundred years so I
think it's just about everything if you
think a few hundred years back yeah they
were still using leeches and
bloodletting and had these crazy ideas
about how the world operates yeah sure
you know the Sun revolves around the
earth and all this crazy stuff I think
we're gonna be so far beyond where we
are now that's even hard to predict what
the changes will be one thing I've
learned and I've learned very very few
things over the last several decades but
one of the things that I have learned is
that any plans that I make that bait are
based on estimates or predictions more
than about a year and a half or two
years out are usually irrelevant because
in the mean time things change so much
that whatever predictions I would make
today four five years out are
effectively meaningless so we're really
just guessing here I have no idea what's
that what's gonna be going on in two
hundred years
are you still maintaining that Donald
Trump is not going to be the Republican
nominee I still believe he won't I think
ultimately Trump is not going to be the
2016 Republican nominee yeah one other
quick thing here what about just driving
around to go to work and sit in an
office and then like driving around to
get back home something as technology
continues to improve we're gonna fix
this crazy constant fossil fuel
destruction that is done every day
called commuting right yeah you can
probably commute be a hologram at that
point yeah I think something something's
gonna change with that send me your
thoughts what will be seen as retrograde
or savagery in a couple hundred years